hendricks always prompt 4 15. he's ready
to go the left-handed batting colton
wong to lead it off against kyle
hendricks long takes strike three called
a fastball on the inside corner here is
paul goldsmith [ __ ] up over the mound
glove by horner behind second off
balance throw low dug out by rizzo on
the backhand good play
three up three down
after a half cardinals nothing cubs
coming up that is the line from a friday
night game against the pirates that was
the opener against pittsburgh when kim
was announced as the closer at that time
the bases are loaded and here's the
dangerous ian happ and he needs a
strikeout here
a swing and a miss a 91 mile an hour
fastball strikes out in half big
strikeout there with the bases full and
now kim will go after david body here's
a pitch that's bounced to the shortstop
tommy edmund charges throws on the run
and retires david bode boy what a hurdle
to clear and in half with the bases
loaded and then to get the ground out
leaving three on ladder o'neal leads off
the second inning now the 1-2 on the way
swinging a miss change-up strike three
second strikeout for kyle hendricks two
outs nobody on hendricks has set down
the first five cardinals bounced weakly
to the right side and shallow right
charging and gloving his corner and now
a flip to rizzo and it's another one two
three inning the cardinals have not hit
the ball out of the infield as yet so
nothing nothing game brad miller first
up line drive towards center coming in
elmora makes a sliding cat a sinking
line drive to center almora got a great
jump ray stan made the backhanded
sliding catch on his knees that's the
first ball hit out of the infield by a
red bird here is dexter fowler batting
eighth in the order swinging in a line
drive to right and back is the right
fielder to the track to the wall and
it's gone big fly dexter fowler that one
carried into the
bleachers in right
and the cardinals take a one-nothing
lead fowler
bites his former teammates and the way
the right fielder ian happ was drifting
back to the track looked like he might
have a play shy of the wall then he just
watched it fly out tommy edmond do up
against kyle hendricks popped up short
center field racing in almora dives did
he make the catch he did
he just robbed edmond of what would have
been a double
full extension that's spectacular good
work
leads things off here in the cubs fourth
hap swings drives one to deep left field
going back is o'neill he looks up this
is into the bleachers for a home run the
cups tie up the game
a solo shot to left for ian happ
1-1 here in the fourth
half gets an inside fastball now he sees
three pitches in a row
all off speed pitches and then kim tries
to come in hard with a four seamer it's
about belt high and half punches ball
either way you've got a runner at first
and miller and fowler at the plate hit
high in the air to center field and that
is going to stay in the ballpark as
albora settles under it fowler is
retired the cardinals strand their first
runner tie game one to one bottom of the
fifth inning and here's anthony rizzo
the breaking ball swinging a miss he
struck him out so he has now struck out
three out of four batters and gant looks
sharp two outs nobody on three bowls two
strikes on tommy edmond ground ball to
the left side bias has to hurry gloves
it throws to first gets him hendricks
pitching a good ball game let's see if
the cubs can get him a run and get him a
win giovanni gallegos takes over for
john gant came in in the fourth with two
outs and nobody on and pitched very well
and now gallegos has the sixth inning he
struck out the side in his last
appearance over the weekend a swing and
a miss he went for a slider low out of
the zone strike three that's four
strikeouts out of the last five batters
for the cardinals bullpen now wilson
contreras pitch is swung on a ground
ball right to colton wong playing up the
middle of the infield he throws out
contreras two up two down strike out of
baez ground out for contreras and ian
happ is a man who tied the game hitting
a home run off kwang young kim pitch is
swung on and missed a slider strikes out
half gold schmidt at second base he
doubled to start this it's still three
and two on o'neal curve in the dirty
walked him good at back first and second
nobody out for matt carpenter a swing
and there's a shot into right field at
base hit holding up over at third base
paul goldschmidt the bases are loaded
nobody up dylan carlson is coming up
up the middle baez will throw to the
plate for one that's all they'll get
six to two on the fielder's choice base
is still loaded with one away the bases
are loaded one out he's on in relief of
hendricks the pitch and miller hits a
fly ball into left center field elmore
won't get there one run is it here comes
another how about one more the play at
the plate and carlson is out but miller
drives in two and the cardinals go on
top 3-1
brad miller comes on through
the cubs are down to their last out
swung on hot shot to goldsmith he races
to first for a red bird winner almora
grounds out sharply to paul goldschmidt
and game one of the doubleheader comes
to an end